voilà geronimo le bateau dont olivier
lecat chose dont ils retard le 12
janvier et vont avoir envie quand même
un parcellaire terrible c'est génial ça
souffle ses plus beaux pays et c'est le
blues ces jeux des lignes et c'est le
plus beau pays du monde
oui la mer c'est extraordinaire a fait
un parti quand exactement
dès que les vents sont favorables nous
on est prêt à partir mais il faut encore
avoir des vents favorables actuellement
y'a pas d'alizée c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'air entre gibraltar et la latitude du
cap vert moi ya pas d intérêt 120 voix
choisir sa météo et oui on part quand on
de la wii c'est le propre des records
c'est la vente six mois le président il
profite
non mais vous acceptez de vous occuper
des associations mais n'a filmé ce que
c'est de la course au large mais un jour
je m'occuperai de pétrole peut-être si
personne ne veut y aller en iran non
mais on n'ira pas dans les bious spécial
ce que je vais vous dire c'est qu'on
vous aidera à vous soutiendra parce que
je pense qu'il faut qu'à un moment une
grande gueule comme ça qu'ils parlent de
la mer grande gueule non il parle
l'autre